oh
he's not even fighting okay
well down bad he is so in love with that
so in love I'm so in love are your kids
and your kids and your kids your kids
you guys welcome back to dinner
rockstars we've jumped ahead another 10
years in Westeros and along with some
new actors portraying our leads we also
have a bunch of new kids running around
the red keep but who is the father of
all these new offsprings wait
uh you guys this is a big question
presents talking dragons our weekly
fantasy after show where we talk about
everything about dragons anything
anything and everything Fantasy Dragons
we cover it yeah we cover it all and
also who's the daddy who's the daddy I'm
Jessica Clements and with me today is
Brandon Barrick hello hello welcome back
and as always we're gonna try and not
spoil anything from the books uh we'll
reference stuff from the past we can
reference things that are way ahead in
the Game of Thrones but we won't spoil
anything on the show we're watching it
we're enjoying it we're going to talk a
little Tolkien today as well covering
some rings of power but first we got to
get into this episode of House and the
dragon so good let's do a quick recap of
episode six of House of the Dragon The
Princess and the queen
as Jessica said it's been 10 years since
the last episode and we opened on
Rainier giving birth to a son uh
childbirth was her greatest fear when we
last saw her but now she's giving birth
to her third son in fact uh she's
already given birth to jacaris and
luceris they go by like Jason Luke very
very very modern Lenor will name this
third one Joffrey if you remember that
name that was his lover who got killed
by Sir Kristen Cole during the wedding
Feast uh though it's clear that many in
the castle are wise to the fact that
Lenor is not the father of any of these
kids uh they don't have the trademark
hair that we've come to expect from the
targaryens and the valet Rams it's so
ridiculous it's like that is the main
thing and they don't have it clearly is
not keep those kids in the Attic
literally I would be like oh you can't
come out you can't come out they'll know
uh as soon as this third kid is born
like literally it's out of the womb and
Allison has called to see the child
immediately uh Rainier decides to bring
her son to Allison herself still
bleeding from childbirth you know
passing her after birth on the way the
stairs brutal stuff really brutal stuff
as you guessed it the relationship
between Alice and radera has only eroded
even further uh it's clearly a constant
struggle of small power plays between
them uh here in King's Landing me
meanwhile our boy viserys is looking
rough he's down a whole ass arm he's
missing the Arches hanging there
desperately and they let him hold the
kid which I'd be careful letting my
one-armed dad uh grab the kids oh don't
be rude at this point now I'm just
feeling bad for my series I mean just
let him go the last episode there were
five times I thought he was gonna drop
dead like he's bleeding he's passing out
he's a mess he's made it 10 more years
but he is he is looking rough he's
looking really rough uh Allison is aware
that rhaenyra is not having kids with
sir lanor and just pissed that viserys
won't acknowledge it uh she says to Sir
Leonard do keep trying sir lanor sooner
or later you might get one that looks
like you just devastating stuff uh plus
sir Kristen Cole is there to feed her
hatred of Ray Mira uh dropping a sea
bomb on the girl that he once loved oh
my God he's so hurt he's so hurt and I
love how Allison is like you can't say
that word please don't say that word
still my daughter still my daughter
still my stepdaughter still my old best
best friend uh so so Harwin strong brake
bones is the commander of the city watch
and clearly the father of these three
sons uh plenty of people in the class in
the castle seem to have noticed things
as well including jacaris uh this also
might explain why jacarius is not great
with his Dragon ver Max yeah that was
that was really sad what just Harris
goes as well I was like am I a bastard
am I a baby bastard yeah it's okay my
guy it's okay I I love them I love them
so much I know they're so sweet so
Allison adversaries have three kids
aegon Elena and Amon aegon has a dragon
Sunfire uh but no real ambition to try
to take the throne while aemon's dragon
egg never attached and the other kids
like to tease him about it and it's
really mean and I hate it they give him
a dragon named the pink dread it's a pig
it's like look at that it's a damn Pig I
hate I hated the scene I wanted I was
like go off I was like go off Helena
clearly has her own interest in her bugs
and maybe is a dreamer like her father
yeah yeah yeah it was interesting there
was a lot of talk about dragons and
pairing the dragons with children and we
see Elena later explained to her
daughter whose Dragon Age never dragon
egg never hatched she was like that
happens most of the time like half the
time they don't hatch but it's also a
great analogy for people yep like half
of these kids don't get born and half
the time the mother dies and it's like a
real real struggle I love the metaphor
of like yeah some eggs just don't hatch
what did I do yeah yeah that's just how
it goes so many kids now let's get into
it but there's just so many kids right
well speaking of Elena Dana and Lena are
touring the lands with their dragons
curraxis and vagar vegar the dragon this
is one of the original dragons that came
over with aegon the Conqueror and helped
take over Westeros looking old looking
big looking just geriatric but she's
she's a big old lady and she's seen a
lot of battle out there and these two
dragons have flown together before uh
this these were like these demons and
Raymond nieces parents flew these
dragons together so like they're they're
good friend dragons uh currently Damon
and Elena are hanging out in pentos and
it's there that Prince Reggio wants to
make Damon their lord to defend them
against the rising threat of the
triarchy the triarchy's back baby uh
they've partnered with Dorne uh and no
one's been watching the stepson so
they're getting powerful again uh Elena
wants to go back to driftmark and die a
dragon Rider's death but it's clear that
Damon wants nothing to do with Westeros
so Elena's like I'm sick of just touring
around being a show for all these like
rich people who want to see our dragons
like let's go back I want to be in
driftmark I want to be where my home is
uh Damon and Lena have two twin
daughters Reyna and Bayla but Lena is
pregnant again and the labor is not
going well the doctor says the baby will
not come out and will likely not survive
very similar to what viserys went
through with Emma we were talking about
this Damon he he thinks about what's
happening but we both agree Damon would
never be like yeah killer get the baby
out like he didn't want to make that
call I don't think I don't think he did
but I also don't think he cared it was
weird I think he's kind of when they
were riding together he seemed to have
affection he loved her but I think he
also was like I think he's still there's
still a goal there in mind and I think
when she was giving birth I don't know
for me it came off more so like oh well
take it out yeah yeah I don't know he
was like I don't really care well
regardless Lena's not letting anyone
make decisions decision for her she
drags herself out to her dragon vagar
and orders her to burn her alive like
and poor vegar was like are you sure say
drug Paris he said if you say it for the
fourth time I'm gonna have to I love how
this old lady dragon is just like
sleeping on the beach and it's like what
do you want me to do the court the
charred Corp stays there and the dragon
turns around yeah yeah dragon's like
well back to bed I guess I guess we'll
go back to the job's done who's gonna
ride my back uh at King's Landings or
Christian Cole and break bones get into
it during uh some sword training with
the kids with drinking uh with a
drinking viserys looking on he has this
like little I was like that was big dad
at the softball game or the t-ball game
energy just like drinking up there like
and those two are mine and those two are
my grandkids okay you believe it he
didn't say a single thing he was just
like oh well when there was a point when
when Chris when uh break bones grabs uh
amond and uh visares yells at Emma he's
like hey man yeah it's like uh this boy
this man just laid hands on your boy oh
boy uh so Lionel strong winds up Lane
into Christian Cole literally getting
him right in the face uh which really
pisses off his dad the hand of the king
Lionel strong Lionel later tries to
resign over his son's actions and the
shadow that looms over his house but
willfully blind viserys won't hear it
yeah he loves him even like uh Allison's
there like
what are you doing he does agree to let
Lionel take uh Lionel take his son
Harmon back to harrenhal though yeah
meanwhile laner's been day drinking sir
Carl all right could you see Port Rhino
you know just trying to comfort her her
poor you know breasts full of milk just
in so much pain and you could hear them
coming down the hall just singing and
you're like oh this is not a good time
this is not all I want to say is men
never change y'all
they do it today they do it in AC he
dreams of going off to the stepstones of
fiber Runner reminds him he's not going
anywhere some competing storm metaphors
she commands him to stay I do love like
all these like storm metaphors where
it's like well it's heavy you picked the
metaphor
you could apply it to any situation but
he's also still pissing me off because
I'm like
clearly how are you you're just like
basking and being right right
yeah we need to settle this it sounds
like a good deal 10 years ago where
you're like oh I can just be the kid
you're so young yeah I can hang out
it'll be fun but like as he points out
he's a knight you know he wants to be
out there fighting he wants to be on his
dragon flying around killing people he
gets a big kick out of that I mean he
says that I think if you do he does it
for a week he'd be like I'd like to go
back I was the thing he just doesn't
want to be like he doesn't want to be
around yeah yeah and royalty he's like I
had fun when it was me and Joffrey just
in the sand yeah in the weeds doing in
the dunes in the dunes doing it doing it
in the dunes baby but this is yeah he's
having less fun and everyone knows
what's up and yeah he's tired of dealing
with Allison yeah yeah at the King's
small Council Lord beesberry is getting
old and he can't keep up he's one of
like the OG guys we saw the first the
first episode of this series and he's
still there he's getting old um they
they kind of bring up the trioke he's
Rising the stepstone so this is
obviously going to be a big deal coming
down uh it gets brought up a couple
times in this episode Alice and rhaenyra
bicker over the best strategy for
dealing with it and as the meeting is
ending rhaenyra brings up The Strife
between her and Allison's family She
lays out a proposal another wedding
proposal she she suggests marrying her
son Jay Harris and Helena Allison
viserys's daughter and also she offers
to give them an egg from Cyrax as a
diary her Dragon if her Dragon lays an
egg she'll give it as like a dire it's
like a big deal but sex is like oh baby
this is great great it's just we want it
let's wrap this up we all good you all
good and Allison is like we'll think
about it please we'll think about it
yeah oh my she's not having it as soon
as she leaves that was my favorite line
when she left she was like wow you can
oh say it yeah here we go Allison is
pissed uh that viserys would even
consider marrying their daughter to one
of rhaenyra's quote plain featured Sons
which was so good and what does she tell
if a serious you tell him what she said
she tells me seriously she says you may
do as you wish has been when I'm cold in
my group All Over My Dead Body when she
walks out too he's like oh and it's so
funny because he with his one arm he's
like oh oh women and I'm like yeah yeah
[ __ ] Allison is going to take it she's
like helping him he's like oh can I can
I not even use the privy on my own
when he goes to sit down again and he's
like you're not gonna help me
part of a series Allison and Laris have
dinner uh where Allison laments her
predicament Laris concocts a plan of his
own which involves cutting out the
tongues of some prisoners on death row
yes and putting them under his control
they wear a little Mark of a little bee
which is also Leonor had on his Cane and
then we see it later attached to the
prisoners that go to harrenhal to burn
the strongs alive killing both Lionel
and Harwin and one Fell Swoop Allison
later discovers that Laris is behind the
fire uh when he basically admits it and
claims she didn't wish for this she's
like she's genuinely like kind of
shocked and freaked out but Laris has
shown his willingness to help her
achieve her goals and he wants her to
bring her dad back he's like yeah let's
get Otto back in here my dad's dead now
yeah he's straight up killed his dad I
mean we're good that's our big question
today we'll get into all that uh but
before that we gotta check in with
rhaenyra she decided uh she hasn't even
found out about Harwin yet uh but she
decides it's time to pack up the fam and
Sir Carl gets to come too uh and they
head to Dragonstone uh she's done with
King's Landing she's like let's get out
of here let's get back to Dragonstone uh
you know she's she's down on power right
now she wants to get out of there fam
and and Carl you know what
bring the little [ __ ] boy I'll bring the
little bring the little [ __ ] with you
uh so that's this episode uh before we
get into all of our questions and
discussions we want to remind you to
check out new rockstarsmerch.com where
you can grab our newest latest Obsession
shirt Ashton ruin inspired by the house
of the Dragon series look at that dark
sister I'm wearing it a little bloodworm
action on there uh and when you purchase
this limited edition latest Obsession
shirt you get the opportunity to get a
custom shout out that'll appear right
here on our big question talking dragons
after show uh so check out all of our
awesome merch options awesome merch
options over at New rockstarsmerch.com
so Jessica yes there were a couple of
fiery deaths this week on the show uh
the book that the show is based on is
called Fire and Blood after all uh but
the most shocking death by fire came not
at the hands of a dragon okay uh but
rather a man uh concocting a plan to
burn his own brother and father alive in
their family castle but why why Jessica
why I getting up there It All Leads us
to our big question this week what is
laris's plan what what is this plan here
what does he think of doing this
I
without spoiling anything
um yeah don't spoil anything too
um it it just feels like he is the
puppet master and he's trying to get
everyone to listen like he's he's sowing
his own seeds he's like I need to come
up in this right and I also think he's
kind of after one thing which is mainly
just destroying people and ripping them
apart and he's really gross and mean so
I think he's just like hey as long as
I'm in the castle and I can torture
people I don't really I mean he really
loved those tongues getting cut out and
he loves starting [ __ ] yeah I think he's
just not like I don't know how to
connect like being a masochist like this
and being like
uh also stirring [ __ ] within the queen
and all that stuff but it's like
it goes hand in hand I guess for him and
he's like I like this yeah I love sewing
I've seen people point out that like
Laris if you think of like Varys and
Littlefinger right that we know from
Game of Thrones he's like a combination
of the two of those no 100 whereas
Littlefinger might put a thousand little
plans in place to get to his eventual
end Laris like skipped all of that and
was like I'll just kill my father and my
brother Larry seems to jump up a little
bit much more like headstrong and he's
like I'm just gonna he's very headstrong
No One's Gonna think it's him right
right right so he has like club foot
right he has he has a a disability uh
and his brother is like the strongest
Knight in the land his dad clearly loves
his brother uh they're very affectionate
so layers I think is always felt kind of
put off to the side yeah if you remember
when we first met Laris uh during the
episode with the hunt like he's the one
who like sat with the ladies and heard
all the gossip yeah and he's like I have
better company here right he's he's a
very smart guy he knows what's going on
all over the place you know he was the
one in the previous episode that spilled
Moon tea yes to Allison about what was
going on there so it's like he's always
moving these things in action as we saw
uh when he kind of revealed to Elsa at
the end of the episode he's holding that
same flower that he had held in the
previous episode when he talks about
things that don't belong here but find
their way in anyhow and I think it was
genius to kind of like implicate Allison
in this whole thing because now she's
stuck yeah because she's like well this
is what I wanted yes you're right it's
like I didn't ask for this but now
everyone's going to assume that I asked
for this he has a i and maybe that's
what we're going to see further in the
series is him taking he's like I have a
piece on you and you yeah and you and
you he's got collateral and I love the
series is just more showing of like
little siblings don't want to stand
there like if you're the youngest you
don't want to stand you wanna second
Sons yeah if you want to be the second
no one wants to be the second so they're
taking what's there because now he's the
Lord of harrenhal Yeah by killing his
father and Sir Harwin who was gonna
become the Lord of Herron hall now he's
the Lord of Heron Hall so in one fell
fiery swoop he he gets to be the Lord of
Aaron Hall he controls all that and he
puts like the queen right in his pocket
yeah he's like [ __ ] I owe you and now
he's gonna get he's gonna get a hand of
the king in there that he knows is gonna
be on his side Otto's Gonna Love what he
hears about all this this is like right
up on us alley it's it but then it's
like I understand your game but like
it's such an easy fall it like it can
all crumble yeah and then you will be
the one dead at the end of it so why are
you putting so many eggs in this basket
I would have just called it quits with
Allison I'd be like oh I got the queen
well this is also it's very smart
because yes he's on team Allison he's
he's observed a lot over these years and
he's put his stake with her right he
thinks like oh Allison's gonna come out
on top here in the end but if she
doesn't if she doesn't come out on top
and Rainier gets power he's just gonna
switch he could tell Ray Mira you're
stepmother Allison made me kill yeah
your lover the father of three of your
children
that he'll never get to see again oh
that was so sad when he was saying
goodbye and he was like when I come back
they won't recognize me
it's not your kids it is his kids it is
his kids but it's not supposed to be
politically we know they're not supposed
to be together listen we can talk about
logistics of how they should work I know
that you you're driven by love and I'm
driven by being smart and let me tell
you and let me tell you you don't even
look at me don't look at these kids act
like you don't even know them it's not a
good look to have
holding the brand newborn baby being
like oh look at him being so influencers
cut people's balls off
still you're writing it more people are
gonna keep talking if he's more why is
he in your room why is he holding a baby
she was very Cavalier about it and that
that's kind of been her whole attitude
it is remember when she was out in the
streets watching the Mummers first she
said basically I don't care what people
think right I don't care what the small
folk think she doesn't care what people
in the castle think about her they can
clearly see what's going on but she
doesn't care it's gonna be her demand it
is going to be a downfall for her and
I'm just like I would have been like hey
once we have a baby you can't be can't
be around all the time like that all the
time my dude you can come sneak in at
night maybe Chase is clearly up to
what's going on yeah he's figuring
around child knows he's figured it out
he's like I'm all your bastard mama mama
I'm all you bastard
oh oh my poor guy I love the bastards in
this show except for the one bad one
they're all bad ones uh uh yeah I think
Larry Larry's playing here is pretty
pretty clever he's clearly also like
it's iconic I mean yeah no he's demented
he he is he's worse than the maesters
because I don't know if anyone else died
in that fight we only saw two bodies get
carted out but like in theory like a lot
of people could have done that fire I
don't know what happened uh he picks
these guys on death row uh he cuts out
their tongues presumably so they can't
spill the beans later I also assume
these guys can't write like we assume
they can't like write down what happened
right they're probably from flea bottom
there criminals they never learned how
to read or write I do yeah why well I
don't know if that if these guys are
gonna come back to bite them in the end
he's obviously I don't think that's
still right so oh no yeah they get to
write down like hilarious made me do it
that's probably why they didn't care
that I'm like they're just like we just
care about the tongues also that scene
of cutting off the tongue oh I was like
they showed it
they showed it they got it hot and then
they sliced it like it was a cheese
butter it was this was a heavy episode
for sounds
a lot of those child birth scenes The
Sounds we heard were were very intense
very intense stuff uh uh crazy crazy
stuff crazy
um so do you think Larissa's plan it's
obviously gonna fall apart at some point
like I don't think it might in the world
of Game of Thrones and House of the
Dragon plans fall apart like that's
that's what we are the thing is yes but
I think he's also smart smart uh where
I'm like he yeah he was sitting with the
ladies he was like I'm listening on All
the gossip I know everything that's
going on so I think he has plan B C D
whatever until someone physically kills
him that's the only time his plan will
fail someone kills him because I think
that Allison following through falling
through could he would go to renera and
be like
until it doesn't work and then he's
gonna well I don't even want to spoil it
we can probably talk more and it'll
probably change through our conversation
but he got The High Ground this week
this is power ranging his way up yeah
spoiler it's way up uh I was looking at
back in the book I couldn't find any
reference to like the b or like uh if
it's supposed to be a bug or a beetle or
a B it kind of looks like a B I thought
it was B yeah uh like this might be
something they're kind of like Adventure
for the show it was very it was a really
cool contextual clue for the audience to
be like oh I see the beyond the king
yeah because otherwise we just see a guy
with like yeah because it's hard to tell
it's like is he do I know that guy yeah
it kind of looks familiar I'm not trying
to be a horrible person for a minute I
was like is that sir Chris and I thought
it was uh Harwin yeah we kind of look
like I think it's the white man with
thick beards in the show that I was like
and he was big and bulky too it's tough
to tell it's tough to tell uh we got a
lot of other questions to get to uh on
today's episode of talking to dragons
but first we want to thank one of our
sponsors and that's a vast Avast is a
global leader in cyber protection for
more than 30 years and trusted by over
435 million users and prevents over 1.5
billion attacks every month on your
computers a vast all in a vast new
all-in-one solution a fast one helps you
take control of your safety and privacy
online through a range of features a
vast one is their best protection yet
giving you everything you need to take
control of your safety and privacy
online and accessible through a single
easy to use interface a vast multitude
of features provide you with privacy and
security as you scour the web and even
help with your machine's performance
personally I like a vast award-winning
antivirus that stops viruses and malware
from harming my devices as well as their
data breach monitoring that will alert
you if online accounts have been
compromised this is really great because
a lot of times the companies don't tell
you like oh they hacked our system when
they got all your information true you
don't hear that from the company a bass
will let you know and just tell you that
you need to change your password they
even have PC speed up which optimizes
the background activity of your apps in
order to speed up your PC and make it
work real smooth thank you to Avast for
supporting big question confidently take
control of your online world with a vast
one it helps you stay safe from viruses
phishing attacks ransomware hacking
attempts and other cyber crimes learn
more about avast1 at avast.com again
it's a vast one at avast.com we also
want to give a quick little shout out uh
to our friends at secretlab who made
these really cool house of the Dragon
sigil office chairs they also have some
Game of Thrones office chairs uh they're
really nice they're high quality you can
find all of these models they have over
at secretlab.com Game of Thrones again
that's secretlab.com
of Thrones they make really nice chairs
we have these around the office now we
have to do a ton of research for this
show we got to sit and watch the show
look at these beautiful chairs oh look
at the stitching look at the stitches oh
so nice these are very comfortable nice
weather chairs and they look so cool
they have like all sorts of different
designs you can check them out on their
website again that's secretlab dot Co
slash Game of Thrones uh and thank you
to secret lab for sending us these
chairs they're so nice and comfortable
obsessed Jessica I'm obsessed because
you also get to choose which in the
office which house yeah yeah there was a
big debate over I'm House Targaryen
which one people get
watch out well it's also because uh well
I didn't want I didn't want the Starks
anyways but Tommy was like Tommy was
Tommy grabbed the Stars yeah yeah
I'm not I'm not getting that House
Lannister especially
on um the one in this this season has
the dragon uh Joe is it Jason is it
Jason well Jason's one of them they're
twins I hated him
yeah Jason and Thailand are the two yeah
I know but Jason is a real jerk it's
true uh Jessica I got another question
for you A big question presents talking
dragons
who's going to ride Vegas now I think
it's going to be uh the daughter I mean
they kind of said that right yeah yeah
that doesn't have an egg because you can
still learn to ride a dragon other
people at lane or even learned to ride
uh well yeah Lena tells her daughter
like hey I didn't my dragon didn't hatch
either but I get to ride Vegas it's like
writing uh the Michael Jordan around
honestly real talk real time this is an
All-Star Dragon okay absolutely balon's
dead right the other big one that came
with aegon in the initial Conquest but
veg are still around and vegar oh she
ain't she ain't putting up with no BS I
mean she's a big old dragon and it'll be
nice for her because it kind of feels
like that same connection that she had
with her mom with her mom yeah yeah I
yeah I I hope it is her that gets to
take control of the Dragon and also I
don't think like unlike we're seeing
with uh freaking uh rhaenerys children
trying to train their dragon they are so
old that it's like you don't really need
to tame me I'll do whatever yeah well
that's the other thing but will it
listen uh yeah they make a big point of
point you know when they're training the
young kids uh in the dragon pit that
kind of uh I know Dragon trainer guy is
like you know who's only speaking in
high Valerian I did like I did like that
the kids know a little high Valerian but
then not enough to understand his full
conversation they don't even translate
it for the audience which I thought was
really fun because we're kind of in the
kids perspective but they say like once
you bond with a dragon only listen to
you right but will it will I don't know
if Vigor will listen they don't listen
watch it and then she'll be like I don't
want to watch I'll just get that
heartfelt moment like where she's like
sad about her mom being dead and goes up
to the dragon like puts her forehead on
the dragon in the dragon's life hey I
let her save your car is like five times
she she said it okay don't be mad at me
don't come
I mean they make a big point on the show
about the power of the Dragons right we
have four dragons They have ten dragons
that's very important and we know if if
you're we're about to have the dance of
the Dragons right when these kind of
chess pieces start battling it out uh
having an old Dragon like Veigar you can
a good way to kill a dragon is with a
bigger older dragon vegar has killed
other dragons before uh during like the
battle under God's eye and stuff like
that uh so having a dragon like I mean
Vega you saw it next to uh caraxi's the
blood worm who is a big long lanky
Dragon but vegar could eat these for
breakfast that scene was so insane of
just look how big that thing is yeah
yeah so like having vegar on your side
that's a powerful Ally uh so whoever
gets vegar is going to have a lot of
power uh in this show I got another
question for you Jessica yeah this one
I thought they would address it I don't
know do we think Damon is the father of
these twins these twin girls there there
is an interesting line uh where the one
daughter who's a dragon didn't hatch uh
apologies I forget which one's which
they're twins uh and they do like she's
she's like Dad doesn't even talk to me
basically because he's real standoffish
and even at the end uh you know after we
see the the charred corpse the kids are
looking at their mom's charred corpse
clean the beach please exactly look at
how kind of dismissive he is he's not
hugging them no he walks away I also I'm
like he truly is like I'm unemotional
well and we know from the last episode
he never consummated his marriage with
Ray Royce and we've seen a couple times
throughout the show his impotency when
it comes to loving the ladies do we
think that he was able to get uh these
two heirs in one session at least one
session of lovemaking with his wife and
he produces these two children do you
think do you think is their time
I'm questioning that I don't think he is
but then I was also the reason I don't
think he is was when she one got an egg
one didn't get an egg and I was like
okay
it's iffy it's iffy sometimes it doesn't
work but also we want to think lineage
maybe there's something fishy in the
lineage but it's like it still is 50 50
with twins so I don't know and I love
the storyline where it's like I'm the
strongest man I am strong I murder I
don't care and it's like but you're
impotent yeah so one thing you can't do
is secure your family's life so I still
want to keep that storyline going for my
own sake of I like I just think it's
great uh to show that he is weak in one
point and not at all so I'm like I want
to say it's not his kids maybe maybe not
and again but she's like okay with she
still loves him but she's also she's
also
like teen when she like physically they
danced right yes so he was 12 when she
was offered
she went through a walk in the garden
she was like 12. she was offered to the
brother and then it was like a few years
ago by maybe four years man I forget uh
two to four years so she's closer to
1516 at the wedding so now she's like
26. and well the reason she went up to
Damon was like oh girls talk about yeah
so it's like yeah you're probably so
impressionable this is the first man
you're sleeping with the first everyone
sees you with the hot the hot stud
that's the brother of
the crib
okay well there was there was also like
that marriage that was being arranged uh
with someone from Bravos
I think it was alive to go quicker but
she didn't seem to care for Damon
affectionate I think she genuinely is
like I I love him and I think but I
think it's a bad part like I think
rhynara was like I'm not a fool and
you're a [ __ ] idiot but Lane
unfortunately I mean Rainier was always
like do it if you're this big bad guy
then yeah go ahead show it put your
money where your mouth is
like and she probably honestly feels bad
she's been on the road for 10 years
flying around and she's like I just want
to go home and I I want to like do my
doodling he's like yeah I kind of like
being on the road it's kind of fun don't
you like being a weird circus now he's
got these two kids uh and not that
there's anything wrong with daughters he
has these two daughters the the baby
that wasn't born uh we know in the book
it was still born and it was a male so
we can assume it was a male for a second
I thought
the child could have survived that's
actually my next question for you
Jessica uh for a second I thought well
they're doing this fire so in the book
Lena uh has the stillborn child child
and then it's described and again
remember the book Fire and Blood is it's
told it's a story that was passed down
and being retold so unreliable narrator
but basically she goes out to her Dragon
uh for what people assume so she can
have one last ride uh but dies before
she gets on a dragon I love the agency
that they've done with the show here
where instead of that it's like no I'm
not gonna die during childbirth I'm
going to die a dragon rider at the in in
the fiery breath of a dragon right that
we know that like targaryens they have
like a little fire resistance to them
right we saw in the first step of
episode but Sarah's kind of holding his
hand over the fire in Game of Thrones
Daenerys the unburnt the unburnt
for a second I thought like baby can't
come out burn me away baby will be come
out baby will still be alive now this
baby doesn't survive in the book so this
would be a big change for the show for a
second I thought it was possible I
thought there was going to be like a
baby
in this show were the saddest thing ever
oh maybe a little stray from the book
and they don't yeah and I and they they
can't and so I think well they could
they can do little things like the
little B they can do those little things
they can do tiny things like well they
and they can also like change the age a
little bit they can they can give us
exactly what happened as opposed to the
book which is like we don't know what
happened yeah right it's just I keep
being like oh this isn't like the Harwin
strong dying I was like oh this isn't it
is it an oh okay five episodes you had
read the book and you're like oh they're
going back to Herring Hall uh-oh but it
was like we're going back to Heron Hall
I was like oh they're gonna travel it's
gonna take like they'll take a few weeks
I think I know he's sleeping and there's
a red line in the door you're like oh
boy that is screaming
they really didn't show I mean we saw a
Lionel and we saw him calling out for
her and we can't see her for a second
but then they also drag out these bodies
if they don't show and I was like is he
dead do you think Lionel strong the dad
is alive well no I wasn't sure who
because they weren't really clear with
it but then at the End lyrics is like no
they didn't oh they did oh they did oh
my God just got the Raven just got the
Raven they did they did I sent it
actually I sent it around it just flew
right back
um okay this next thing I want to talk
about we're going to be careful with
this because we won't spoil anything uh
but I feel like we have got to talk
about at this point what is up with
these rats Jessica there's a rapper
episode and it's doing something weird
we're seeing rats all the time
at first I was like oh these shots are
just to signify how dirty or open or
wide these spaces are right and then
once the rest are getting closer I was
like okay give me a second what the what
the hell is this about yeah yeah we're
seeing these rats you know he sees it
again we've seen in a rant in the last
episode eating the blood of Joffrey uh
in in the banquet hall or in the throne
room yeah I mean these rats are
important they are it is going to pay
off if you're watching and being like
wow I keep showing these rats it'll be
important I don't know when I can't tell
you when and I can't tell you why
but just pay attention to them they're
there I mean people have uh made the
analogy to The Departed right you see
the rat at the end of that movie it
signifies like there's a rat you know
like there's obviously like a rat in the
castle too several different rats right
I thought it was somewhat of a rap I was
like I thought it was just that there's
a rat in the castle yeah you've got uh
uh you could say Harwin was a rat like
you know having kids with with the air
to the Iron Throne like out of web like
like these there's rats everywhere I
think it also signifies the Decay right
we kind of heard at the beginning of
this series like King's Landing this was
a time of peace right through Joe Harris
everything's great at the beginning of
this season you know they talk about
when Damon was in trouble charge of the
city watch it was like City's a mess
like there's crime everywhere like
things are in bad shape I think the
castle itself is kind of in Decay this
is showing that these rats are able to
see ground it also points to like these
secret tunnels right there's like
passageways in the Kingdom you don't
know about yeah and things going on
there we saw Rainier using her secret
tunnel again this week to do a little
eavesdropping she's a little rat she's a
little rat creeping around the castle uh
so yeah the rats are important don't
worry folks the rats are important keep
your eyes on the rats
um do you have anything more you want to
talk about with House of Thrones House
of Thrones House of the Dragon before we
uh house our powers do a little
something else no I think I can't wait
till we do our who's okay okay well
before we get to our power rankings it's
time to do a little talking token flip a
coin that's right we got another episode
of rings of power this week this one was
called partings a lot of people leaving
this week a lot of people saying goodbye
um the most important thing this episode
I think we saw some mysterious folks uh
checking out the spot where the stranger
fell from the sky the little meteorites
crash do you know what those people are
I have no idea who they are uh I am not
well read on the toll team so I'm very
mysterious as to these people look like
actual evil people they do uh I mean
eight are you see Adar he's evil see the
Orcs they're evil these people looked
evil they're like where's our evil
clearly like zealots yeah are they
helping are they the ones helping Sauron
are they there for Sarah there for
something else they had like a shield
that kind of have the star pattern on it
yeah these are clearly not good people
uh meanwhile Brown she's trying to Rally
the people of the Southland uh to fight
against ARG and the Orcs uh but good old
waldrig tries to tuck them all out of it
and winds up convincing about half of
the people to go with him to basically
turn themselves into a dog and say we
love you uh it's a bad idea guys uh Ron
deer has a little archery training with
uh Theo I like to say his boy Theo who I
still think is
uh Theo still hates him but maybe
respects him I don't know he winds up
showing around you the blade Hill he's
like oh I hate you but hey check this
thing out yeah but also also look at
this uh irandia recognizes it he shows
him a forgotten wall that has the blade
carved into it and a reindeer calls it a
key yes not a sword but to what we do
not know I hate this scene
there is like the scene is everyone in
the village just were they eavesdropping
or were they just like oh he's looking
at something
there was two different times in the
village was like let me get in
everyone's damn business yeah and I was
like shut up stay out of my business
stay away uh meanwhile in new Menorah
Galadriel still trying to talk Hall
brand into going with her to the
Southlands uh they got five ships and
500 numenorians it's not gonna be five
ships for long uh Galadriel does a
little orc killing training session of
her own with some of the new recruits
who try really hard to hit her watch the
scene again I mean they this is not
wooden swords folks this isn't when
sword training these are real swords and
she's like try and strike me and they're
like okay and they come 100 at her
intense intense uh meanwhile for
raison's kid Chemin really wants his dad
to take over numenor and not help the
elf and his dad's like just chill out I
got a plan Uh Kevin later sets a boat on
fire which also sets up one more boat
ilsador is there and saves him for some
reason I don't know why was he it
because he loves his sister and his
sister wants to bang him I don't know I
don't know in the end halbrand does
agree to tag along with the new Manor
Convoy and everyone heads out for real
this time including ilsador gets to go
on the boat his buddies get to go on the
boat uh alendra's going out the sister
stays behind she's like the only one
stays behind but everyone is finally for
real actually this time heading off to
Middle Earth uh uh also Muriel's dad the
Old King he got out of bed because he's
worried about the safety of the kingdom
and he warned his daughter not to go to
Middle Earth
he says all that awaits you there is
Darkness honestly and she's like Dad
my whole life you've been preaching
about these albums no and I'm about to
go I've done everything he asked and now
you're like don't go
I don't want to hear it I don't care I
was like girl let's go too late Dad I
said that's a big old man I said my dad
finally rose up from his bed but also
like a crazy old dad is saying crazy
stuff but he said a full sentence I know
but she's also been touching the
planeteer and seeing this wave
destroying New manure she's trying to do
something here look look I know in the
long run neither of them are safe
neither of them are gonna get out well
but it it I would have listened to my
dad the hard foots are still traveling
along with the stranger you know they
make uh Dorian the gang be in the back
uh and the hard foots are still blaming
the stranger for everything that's going
wrong they're in these woods and they're
on characters uncharacteristically bare
uh although animals are gone and this is
this sucks and like this is a stranger's
fault uh and then some wolves show up
and the stranger does a little magic to
scare them off and suddenly the
heartfits are like the stranger's great
we love this guy this is awesome uh
though the magic he does does seem to
cause some physical damage uh to his arm
uh so he winds up putting his arm in
water and like kind of goes into a
magical trance and is saying these words
and like Dory touches them and like gets
Frozen and like ice is coming up like
crazy stuff and it's so it's like he's
doing magic but he doesn't know it
almost very it's also like oh yeah touch
the arm of the magic man yeah that's the
Frozen arm lady and then she runs like
oh and I'm like now are you scared are
you surprised you dummy okay meanwhile
Duran's having dinner with the elves uh
and things are a little tense especially
over a misappropriated stone table which
we later find out was a map story as
soon as it happened I said it's not real
it's not real uh hi King gilgalad uh and
elrond share some words about the true
intention of the elves in Kaza Dune uh
it's true they were looking for the
light of the Lost Cimarron AKA The Myth
roll this was a little bit of a show
invention of the history of mithril here
big change to the lore uh but lrun he
decides to stay loyal so you know the
king tells him like Hey I actually did
send you there so you could find this
stuff so tell me where it is and Horan's
like I literally war on a mountain that
I wouldn't spill This and like if
anything these elves should know that
like Oaths and like promises like that
that's a big deal and if you break a
promise it has like curses yeah he
promised to the Earth yeah that he would
not so he just stayed true to it it
makes me so mad that they were he was
literally like well no tell me and it's
like yeah you think we're gonna die
without the mithril but we're really
gonna die if I tell you I don't like
this High King game at all I don't like
what he's up to uh so he they were there
to find the mithril and it turns out
they're dying the light of the Eldar is
fading uh sella brimbor thinks that if
they can get enough mithril it can save
the elves because it has like this light
inside of it their tree that they
basically it's their Farmer's Almanac
right it's got all these like black
veins going in it and they're like we're
dying we're supposed to live forever and
we're dying we got to do something uh so
elrond is left with the burden of
deciding if he should break his oath to
his friend Prince Duran and what he does
is very Admiral he comes clean to the
prince he's like this listen said I
didn't know what was going on but I'm
telling you now we were there to like
you know get the mithril uh and help
with our impending doom endurance like
oh impending doom I love it Jordan is
basically like if I could be in charge
of the elves we can work I love his work
to get Behavior where he's like no say
it again say it again say I'm the boss
your guys's life is a month say my name
say my name elf
so waldrick brings his bunch of
southlanders to Adar and the Orcs uh and
the Orcs to turn themselves in and
waldrick pledges his loyalty Sauron and
adar's like what did you just say don't
say that name to me
or whoever you are I'll follow you
whatever uh and he's like hey kill this
kid which we don't see but you know
waldrick Tilly does it this is also the
kid that left Theo behind previously so
would you you're mad about it I
genuinely was like I would have done the
same thing and I would have ended up
being that that kid uh deserves to lie
this deserves a dime Choose Your Own
Adventure I would be the first one dead
in this storyline but also I love radar
so the numenoreans are heading off to
Middle Earth and we see the Orcs
marching on ostrith uh they're coming
they're coming uh so that was this
episode of rings of power uh most
importantly we got it we had to do this
every episode pretty much we're on
Sauron watch who is Sauron I still think
it's how brand I still think how brand
is Sarah I don't know it's so
interesting to get his storyline more
because then I'm like oh does that make
him Sauron not like that but like
sauron's past was literally just giving
up right I want to know what's in this
pouch first of all yeah then he keeps
taking off his neck he takes it bang and
he puts it down and comes back and grabs
the soil uh just some soil uh maybe some
cocaine I don't know it's actually spicy
the spice must flow
um I still just wanted to be Theo and I
think I love this idea that it's gonna
be fun if the once his mom dies that's
when he's gonna pull up right and he's
gonna take that hill and he's gonna open
some damn portal that opens everything
and all hell breaks loose
um yeah I just wanted to be him I think
it I mean I know they wanted to be the
stranger right they want us to think
it's the stranger he falls from the sky
he kills some things but like once he
found out he killed those fireflies
he feels really bad about it I think I I
like when someone I can't remember
someone said I think Maven said twice
it's like he he was The Omen he was just
like the like oh here's one other step
he's a sign yeah he's a sign he's not
him he's just like a sign right is is he
is it his magic that enables Sauron to
rise to power just Sauron like use him
in some way uh yeah it's it's clear that
those weird zealots who came to the to
the spot of the meteorite they are there
to help Sauron get to power I'm pretty
sure do you think Adar is like against
Sauron he seems really pissed to hear
that name
which is interesting
um 100 I think he's like more so like I
want to be the strongest I don't want
this fricker to come I want to be sorry
unless he is Sauron he's like don't blow
up my spot guys dude shut up don't say
that kill his kids kill this kid no kill
this kill this kid okay who had the
better combat training this week okay we
had two combat training scenes which I
think was a very interesting parallel
you have Galadriel fighting with the
numenor boys or sir Kristen Cole with
the uncles and his and their nephew the
real question is who's better Galadriel
or sir Christian Cole and I think it's I
think it's galatria I mean she has the
power of an elephant can do those fun
little Hops and and she also has been
doing it clearly much thousands of years
right well she I guess she technically
hasn't gone to war her brother uh she
went to work she was you don't remember
the first episode she was chasing down
Orcs all over the place she's been in
some battles she hasn't been in the war
war because the war was kind of ramped
up yeah when she comes on the field but
she was like chasing down the little
like leftover pockets okay so yeah I
still but I still think answer she's
she's much better fighter I was just I
was just blown away at how hard those
guys were trying I mean like
I know the to get to be the lieutenant
you gotta get a hit but like you could
cut her arm off dude like she's still
trying so hard well that was the whole
point they were never gonna get her I
guess so well one guy gets a little Nick
congratulations don't you give him
anything it's also like don't name him
like be like you guys got to do better
next year yeah be like oh you don't have
to do it today you're now the lieutenant
for scratching up my dress
no I mean I do love I I do like sir
Kristen Cole you know like kind of
calling out uh uh aegon and being like
okay tough guy lord of the straw he
calls him or whatever he's like now you
fight me now you gotta fight me and he
takes out both of aegon and amen is like
just taking them both down I like it I
also love
poor Harwin man seeing his son out there
getting getting beat up and he's like he
grabs him by the chest plate real real
like uh uh a peewee football action
where you grab the shoulder pads grabs
him by the chest plate and we don't hear
what he says but you know he's like you
better get over there you better he said
you better kick his ass
listen your grandpa's up there watching
and I don't mean for Sarah's okay
I don't mean him and adult your grandpas
are up there okay don't mean the old one
drinking from that bottle
[Applause]
uh yeah so good some good action this
week okay here's here's a here's a big
question for you what was a bigger kind
of power play uh uh kind of
Machiavellian move here is it during
convincing the elves to give him the
stone table and carry it all the way
back yes I love that little shot of the
elf kind of like stumbling which is what
I need more of this show she'll be like
the elf stumbling here like stuff like
that was that a bigger power play or or
Laris basically implicating Allison in
the murderous but the the story of the
Stone was really funny that was pretty
it was really good and to be like you
gotta carry it
because like what are the elves gonna be
like they're gonna be like that's not
true that's not true at all it's like we
use it for our teams we use it in the
most spiritual aspects of our
livelihoods and they're what are you
gonna be like uh no thank you yeah
they're like [ __ ] dude now we gotta
carry this big ass and I lost my table
yeah
the inconvenience is so good but the
actual storyline of this is gonna last
longer is hilarious yeah yeah I mean
last that was a very good thing but you
gotta imagine Duran was like thinking on
the Fly there that was yeah no no I
loved it I think it's great I think it's
great but compared to this it can't also
this is so something say something like
a Tokyo elves weeks to decide to take a
shite or something like that yeah just
great stuff I I love the idea of like
time how time works on rings of power
where it's like the elves are so
concerned about like you know the the
bigger picture because they live for so
long but now faced with like their own
mortality they're suddenly like in panic
mode and like we gotta build this giant
furnace we gotta find mithril we gotta
steal from The Elves
and I'm like you guys are also I can't
wait honestly genuinely can't wait for
the next episode where the king's like
absolutely not
like what did I tell you I told you he
was up to no good he was coming here to
take what's ours and they can all die
yeah now do you think someone like
and this is again coming from a
gentleman like me who has not read the
the books and you're about to ask a
woman like me
if it's plausible that someone I don't
trust the elf king Gil Gallant at all
like he is so ashamed he's best he's so
rude no I mean he was the one who sent
Galadriel back he was trying to like get
galadril out of there by being like if
we send her back maybe it'll like fix
the tree no and he knew it wasn't gonna
yeah he just wanted to get there yeah
yeah he just wanted to get her out of
there come on and elrons is trying to do
right by everybody actually now I think
about it maybe I am on his side because
galadrill she was pissing me off I mean
chill this was maybe the first episode
she didn't piss me off actually no
because she named him lieutenant and she
shouldn't have but like she she's just
been upsetting me in ways where I'm like
you're not recognizing the bigger
picture she's so focused you're so
focused and I love that interaction with
her and I think it was all brand where
he was like no you have to tell me
you're making me go back to a place I
don't want to go to you have the
littlest you can do is tell me why and
she's like I just can't well that's why
I think how brand is Sauron because he's
playing her like a fiddle dude he's
using her he's using her so good so well
and she's so it's interesting we talked
about time you know she's so focused on
the immediacy of this but you know it is
happening and then you just stop it but
like for her to be so focused on right
now and not see the bigger people not
see the big difference it's so that's
how someone's gonna lead to power you
guys are gonna you're gonna be so
focused on your own [ __ ] that he's gonna
come in and be like
okay Jessica it's time for your favorite
part of the show we're gonna do our
power rankings okay I love the power uh
and we'll start we'll start with uh
House of the Dragon who is up this week
on House of dragon who gained the most
power
strong my guys this is absolutely no one
else gained power can you give me anyone
else like game Power maybe Carl sir Carl
gained so much power he gets to go on
big guy he got some something he gets to
keep doing what he's doing and now he
gets to go to dragons Okay so so few
people get to go to Dragonstone
is way up this week I think Allison is
obviously way up by proxy though she
made Rainier look like a fool uh I mean
she called out the fact that Rainier was
like lactating which was like rude as
hell but then I uh that stairway scene
where it was like you can do this when
I'm cold and my grave is a reminder that
like he's still the king yeah girl like
he whatever he says goes right
she's she's mad she's all he's such a a
limp read in the world I know but she
still has to deal with him so it's right
but she's dealing so stagnant she's
still I think she's still she's about to
get her dad back which he's he's not
gonna mess around in and be like yeah
and viserys will do whatever Auto
Hightower he says kill those kill her I
mean
that's would she would you bust in on it
on her son busting out you know what I'm
talking about she didn't even blink she
was just like also was that the window
that tommen jumped out of I was thinking
I was thinking it looks exactly I was
like this is the exact shot of one time
I mean I assume a lot of the windows in
the red keeper yeah but it's the exact
same shot before he like the zoo yeah
like it was like him standing there but
[Music]
he's 20 years old uh a sweet sweet angel
so you're saying lots of baby targaryens
going through that window
you're disgusting dropping kids
are like oh my God what is that
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh it's it's uh it's literally the same
scene in succession and I freaking hate
it oh yeah weird like power thing it's
just like standing over this this is
mine but it's also like he has no
aspiration to be king right no poor poor
Allison has risked it all and now this
boy I mean he busted he's like Mom come
on and thank God he like hit it you know
for a Targaryen to not try and uh bang
his mom in that situation his big move
for him good job my guy uh I don't think
he cares because he genuinely was just
he doesn't want to be brushed back his
hair and went I didn't do it he's like
I'm not gonna be the king who cares and
she's like of course she's like [ __ ]
you better be joking you better be
joking I love how we went to a house
that was more women than anything yeah
and now we're there's too many boys
and she's right man if Ray mirror gets
power it's in her best interest to kill
off all these people and she's angry now
and Allison knows how much she's pushed
Ramiro over this last decades and she's
like we cannot mess around you've got to
take this seriously
that's that's that's maybe like the
saddest thing I know I'm going off the
rails here during the power again that's
the saddest thing to me about the
situation is seeing all those boys
interacting now granted they play a
trick on aegon with the pig but that is
light-hearted they're boys they're boys
being boys and they get a lot seeing
them in the yard and they're training
they're gonna it's like all of these
guys could be friends and could get
along if their parents weren't so bad
it's also if it wasn't so political and
this is going to lead to the dance of
the drugs and these boys are going to be
finding each other for real very soon uh
and it's like this all could have been
avoided
genuinely I I was thinking about that
too I was like they're just having fun
yeah and I forget that they're like they
get along and they tease each other and
they're not they're not separated by
sides I mean you pointed out uh all of
Allison's kids always in green always in
green they don't get to wear red around
there
tough stuff tough stuff uh okay who
gained the most power on rings of power
this week who do you think's up the most
in Power this week
I'll tell you mine I think foreign
lovers with her right yeah those are
people who were on the side of the elves
they've left now so he and his son is
the one who was like why are you letting
her do this why are you letting these
he's like son be cool chill out I got a
long-term plan that's true uh I think
he's in a big position of power this
week I agree I I agree with that because
now he's he's got this whole place to
himself uh she's left the king's old and
crazy in his bedroom uh his son's
blowing up ships
insane insane I think he gained a lot of
power I also think you know Adar is
still gaining a lot of power I was gonna
say Adar but then I was like when you
said that I was like that makes sense he
she literally left it to the hands of
him yeah and he's he's got a long-term
plan to get control of this 100 no I
don't think it's gonna work out for new
Menor in the end but yeah but you know
play play when you have it play while
you have it which got it who this week
lost the most power on House of the
Dragon who do you think lost the most
power do the strong still count oh
yeah I think their family did lose power
I don't think Lair is power but the
Strong's in the eyes of everyone else
have lost a lot which is interesting
gained the most power lost the most
power the strongs oh that is very
interesting that's quite a dichotomy I
well I think that's the thing that when
I say that they lost the most power it's
still like even though they're dead what
they've already planted is still going
to be sold like right all the children
just like strongs yeah his kids they're
not but I think people they don't have
gonna affect renera and it's gonna
affect the kids I think the kid's gonna
be like that was my dad and when they
was gonna be like my my lover my lover
he's dead and then like I don't know
what that I think it was The Godfather
either way but I think that it's gonna
it's gonna hold on it's gonna hold on
what they've done and I and I that's why
I think they're down I think they're
you'd think they're pretty damn yeah
yeah because right now at least she left
yeah right now I did leave but like the
Strong's yeah you're totally right well
where's gained the most power like the
Strong's overall lost a lot of power
this week it is tough for their family I
think viserys is still losing oh I guess
I forgot so much power I just completely
forgot about him because he's just dead
he's losing I mean he's he's a dead man
walking forward barely walking uh but
yeah he's just like bored in his
meetings he's drinking all the time he's
just down his wife's calling all the
shots can you believe they were gonna
make a series where we didn't see the
young but serious I know if we were just
gonna look at ugly videos I think the
show was so smart to give us all that
backstory because I think if this show
started with this episode you would be
like oh Allison is just pure evil she's
a Searcy right uh and like you wouldn't
understand that rhaenyra is not pure
good either she's got her own demons and
her own her own struggles and her I'm
really happy we got the young and yeah
I've only seen one of the adult episodes
but the young people episodes are my
favorite they are so fun it set up so
much good stuff and I'm so glad they did
that and I think it was a very smart
move for them to make I agree uh well
that is it for this episode a big
question presents talking dragons be
sure to check us out each and every week
right here on new rockstars where we're
talking about targaryens we're talking
about rings of power we're talking about
it all uh I'm loving both of these shows
I can't wait to see how they wrap up
don't forget to check out our mini great
merch options over at New
rockstarsmerch.com follow Jessica at
Lulu underscore Clemons follow me at
grin and Barrick And subscribe to
bigquestion wherever you get your
podcast thank you so much for tuning in
this week and for joining us on this
journey uh we hope you have a great rest
of your day and we'll see you here next
week thanks for watching goodbye
can we please
[Music]